[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to
gamespot sorry about that false intro
don't worry it was mary kish we have
fired her immediately she is leaving
game spot uh no just kidding she is
leaving game spot though but anyway
welcome back to the lobby this is our
new time at 11 a.m on wednesdays we're
so glad you could join us uh thank you
so much to the people who are joining us
for our first episode here uh it's kind
of a temporary set we are kind of
changing up the set dressing a little
bit but in general this is gonna be the
new time and we got a lot of questions
from the past few days about nintendo
switch things we're gonna talk about um
first off pete brown you're always here
pretty much unfortunately sorry it's
nice to have you again is it yeah p
brown for those who don't know those
reviews that are here at gamespot uh and
kelly hey kelly plague
okay i thought so uh you're the
associate editor here at gamespot i am
you came over from ign you've been
freelancing before that you're pretty uh
experienced but now we are lucky enough
to have you here at gamespot and
good episode to introduce you with uh in
terms of you're a nintendo fan i am or
you know nintendo pretty well i don't
want to like
say we're biased or anything i'll put
her in a box okay yeah she's an
attention she's the nintendo fan here at
gamespot but anyway um quick i just want
to get a few housekeeping things so in
terms of new format of the show i kind
of want to start off every episode with
uh you know like if you saw before we
actually had our mics on during that
kind of black and white intro before the
show went up that's just kind of to get
us warmed up and we figured we're always
just talking about secret embargo stuff
so why not just leak it all to you guys
what did we leak today
um
no i was just ulysses s grants
that is
non-existent middle name yeah but you
didn't believe me so
we'll do history lessons every once in a
while like that um no but yeah we just
wanted to make it like i said more
conversational involve the audience more
so that's just kind of an effort to do
that um and we also have like we're
going to be doing more giveaways we have
this whole storage room full of random
[ __ ] from a lot of different like games
like a lot of cool collector's editions
and we get those and we don't always get
the chance to give them away to our
audience so we want to
do that more uh so to that effect
we have a diablo figure which we're
gonna be giving away um on friday we
have a link on gamespot that should be
live right now uh if you follow gamespot
on twitter they will be tweeting him
right now uh shiva she's in charge of
our twitter account she's also new so um
if you see her on twitter say hi to her
um
we will be giving these away on friday
but there's a link you can go to on
gamespot we'll be tweeting it uh i think
we'll be in the chat on twitch right now
uh if you're on twitch if you're on
youtube apologies um
i think we're mainly uh game so i'll be
like putting the link in the twitch chat
uh so you can go check that out it's not
only that figure it's also there are a
hundred codes for
uh the new hero zul'jin
in uh heroes of the storm i think he's a
warcraft character right yeah sure yes
he is um he or she is zuljin um so the
codes are pretty much available
uh in most countries let me double check
that the uh figure unfortunately is only
north america so if you're not in north
america apologies but the codes will
work if you are in
north america latin america australia
new zealand and southeast asia only
so apologies to our friends in northwest
asia northwest asia
this is not your day any other place but
anyway i'll recap that again at the end
of the episode if i remember
um and friday we will be picking the
winners through that link so anyway
thank you very much
another thing i want to do at the
beginning of episodes is kind of go
through a newsreel so every like
beginning of the week now when we're
going through deciding what to talk
about in the lobby in terms of bigger
segments that will go on youtube later
or just things we want to talk about the
bigger news from the week
a lot of smaller news slips by so i
figured we'd do a newsreel kind of go
through things that have happened that
don't really warrant like 12-minute
discussions uh there's a few today and
from last weekend i wanted to go through
first off this was only like a couple
hours ago that we heard ubisoft bought
freestyle games dj hero guitar hero live
developer
okay it's
it's not like it's not huge but like now
ubisoft has some uh like activisions
that was activation's like main
uh rhythm game music game developer so
yeah but that genre is kind of like
tanked lately yeah isn't ubisoft also
about to be purchased or at least taken
over by vivendi or something so
so who knows because they said they're
renaming ubisoft limington and they said
they're going to be working alongside
other like their other aaa games so i
don't know if they're going to just like
use them as a
like to supplement development on bigger
ubisoft games but
yeah i don't know super weird maybe
switch music games maybe that'll be the
platform for this stuff to live on maybe
we had like quotes from the ubisoft uh
ceo talking about the switch and how but
he didn't sound too stoked on the switch
he was saying like he's like 300 bucks
and then just smaller thing uh microsoft
no longer shares xbox one sales figure
but a new report from research group
super data claims that the console
reached 26 million units sold since
launch november 2013.
um
and that was spotted by gaming bolt but
it was published in report about the
nintendo switch addressing the entire
video game market it also claimed the
ps4 has an install base of nearly 55
million units and that's slightly above
the 53.4 million units sony officially
disclosed earlier this month so there's
some numbers for you um sounds like
sony's still doing well xbox
they had a great year for hardware i
mean if they're going to share their
data any year would be this year because
i think a few months like after the
summer they were dominating sales
but microsoft yeah microsoft was right
especially because but now like we
talked a couple weeks ago about
in general what the future of xbox one
is after like scale bound being
cancelled not a ton of first party
development coming out of it now yeah
not a whole lot because there's like
gears war five presumably halo six
whenever that gets announced but
yeah so we'll see anyway okay and then
good segway another legend of zelda game
might eventually come to nintendo switch
after breath of the wild get out of here
i know what nintendo would make more
sense
producer
oh dude again uma said it so it must be
true
uh in an interview with ign kids it's
captain obvious yeah oh speaking of
captain obvious let me
tell you what else he said i haven't
been able to fully use all the new
features of the switch he said there
could be possibility of another zelda on
nintendo switch and then when asked
about what a news led could do
differently to build on breath of the
wild listen to this scoop
i think the core element of zelda
gameplay kind of stays the same holy
[ __ ]
there's the main character development
as well as characters you meet along the
way and then you learn new things as the
character develops
are you ever
is this insane how is the whole world
not imploding after that kind of he just
described every boring story ever
that's just
basic narrative he just described my
morning commute okay anyway enough of
the news reel let's get into uh our main
segment today talk about the nintendo
switch um
we had a lot of questions in from
readers i will get to those as a promise
there's a bunch between gamespot and uh
twitter and whatnot but uh lucky enough
we have pete here who is at the reveal
event i mean not the reveal event but
the north american event in uh new york
yeah the hands on the hands-on event
right uh so we have a lot of questions
for you people have questions for you in
terms of actually getting to play it and
try things out um just kind of want to
go over basics first uh breath of the
wild release march 3rd
there's no bundles yet they said they
want to keep the price down it's going
to be like 300
uh 299 uh what would that become in the
uk they said like
for the uk prices or sorry for um europe
prices check like local retailers or
something right i don't know what so who
knows but yeah it will be 2.99 in the us
over here 300 um launch lineup breath of
the wild one two switch one two switch
super bomberman r let's go let's go
through so breath of the wild i think
people know it as the legend of zelda
will be wii u and nintendo switch when
you play that game you meet characters
along the way
[Music]
and then the characters change a little
bit oh right i forgot about that and
you'll change you learn more as this
game has everything yeah it'll be it'll
be it sounds like an epic um right so
okay
that one-two switch which is a game that
utilizes the joy-cons which are the
little like handheld remote things that
attach to the tablet and it uses them in
a lot of different ways that would be
the one people know for the milking
thing the milking they had the dual
for those who don't know and so we're
not just talking about milking without
context can you explain that uh so let
me so the the joy cons these controllers
they have motion they can detect motion
and they have little cameras that can
detect like gestures in front of it some
of the minigames make use of the various
features the milking one it detects you
know you're moving up and down and
pressing buttons trying to milk a cow
um
and you're competing against someone
else who's milking another imagine uh
imaginary cow it sounds so weird but one
of the things about this game is that
when you're doing it you're basically
face forward looking at somebody else
now i don't even know how you people
deal with your close friends but i can't
stand to like stare at mike for more
than a couple seconds before i feel
awkward maybe that's just you but yeah
lucky for you we sit across from each
other yeah it's great but imagine at a
party right you and a total stranger are
going to be milking imaginary cows while
like
deadlocked in a stair it's it's super
weird
i don't i don't want to do that you'd be
surprised though it's it's it's a new
feeling like it it's definitely
different than anything else i've
experienced playing a video game yeah i
was surprised this wasn't a bundle
thing because it's sort of like a mini
game compilation kind of style game like
party game and you'd think in line with
like sports or i mean nintendo land to a
much lesser extent obviously i was
really surprised that they didn't and
it's like 50 i think yeah i'm also
surprised
yeah i mean there's a bunch of mini
games it's not just milking right like
there's one where you have to guess how
many things are inside a little box by
moving it and like using the vibration
there's one we have to like eat in front
of the controller by chewing as fast as
possible uh there's like ping-pong you
can play like the list kind of goes on
there's a lot there
but yes it's the showcase of technology
which you think would be the great
a great thing for nintendo to have with
every switch because then no matter
where someone is if they see switch they
will play one two switch like the
nintendo land or the wii series as she
said yeah yeah but the but reggie you
know talked to him and he was like well
you know by not including this game
we're giving people the chance to choose
the games they want and we're not
raising the price of the system he
equated it more to we play which was
that follow-up to wii sports that came
out with wii but that also came at a
time when there was new hardware the wii
motion plus
so i don't really get i don't really
jive with his comparison but um
it's certainly a fascinating game what
do you guys think of other games right
now it's about like were you a splatoon
fan cali yeah i played so tuned uh my
biggest problem with splatoon was the
lack of voice chat which i understand
but for a
game where there's
actual you can get a strategy together
you can be a heavy or you can be kind of
like the equivalent of a scout in tf2
like there's different loadouts you can
do in splatoon there's actually layers
to it uh not having that like i would
just be on skype with people that i knew
and it really limited the experience um
and so for switch i know they have like
that mobile app for voice chat i don't
know what the capability would be um so
that would be the biggest thing i would
be looking for in splatoon 2. um but i
really enjoy splatoon it's it's fun it's
different
did you immediately know it was a sequel
when they showed it at the reveal or
because i mean there were rumors about a
port right so i thought that's what this
was and then with new weapons and
characters but they're like no it's a
complete sequel i didn't play my
splatoon so i would be the last person
to know but a few people in the office
were like oh this is an entire sequel i
was not expecting i i straight up
thought it would be a port because i
feel like we a lot of us expected that
after kind of thinking oh mario kart 8
is going to be a port um which turned
out to be sort of true they get it it's
a deluxe edition instead but i thought
this was going to be important and i was
like nope splatoon i wish they called i
wish they put a two in there there's so
many opportunities to mess with the name
and this is coming i think september so
it's not quite a launch title yeah uh to
go back to what you were saying about
using a smartphone app to do voice chat
basically the message is if you don't
have a smartphone your switch experience
is going to be lesser yeah like
multiplayer will probably not be a thing
for you um
reggie basically said well if you don't
have a smartphone the switch isn't free
when i talk to him which is kind of
crazy
his reasoning was everywhere i go kids
as young as five have smartphones so who
doesn't have a smartphone so who are we
really leaving out
uh a lot of people
yeah and it feels like some of the
like some of the one-two switch games
that are you know like trying to prove
the or being like a proof of concept for
the tech are geared toward like the
family crowd and maybe the the younger
crowd and i don't see how that lines up
with their you know you need a
smartphone for this yeah i mean like i
know
like i have nieces and nephews who are
10 and under they all have access to
smart devices but they're not really
like theirs right
so i think for kids it's a good means
for parents to sort of regain control
over what their kids are doing like you
can set limits from your phone like okay
the system won't work after this time
like you can do stuff like that um
but just very curious to see them you
know it's nintendo right so we expect
they're going to present hoops that
people have to jump through to do
things that other platforms have figured
out long time ago i'm just surprised
it's this that it's tying it to another
piece of hardware yeah i mean i i guess
i can see like nintendo expanding into
the mobile market with mario run and
even the
the success of pokemon go sort of
indicates that the
the i guess the equivalent of an
installed base is there for
smartphone users and nintendo but
it's still really bizarre like a
three-year-old you will use their
parents phone i guess yeah i don't know
it's weird to me from a business
perspective i get it because to your
point it's sort of like solidifying
nintendo's relationship with mobile
devices yeah so even away from switch
you'll look at your phone and still
have that subconscious idea of nintendo
in your hand yeah and so you'll go to
their other games
but for the average person just seems
like it's going to be a pain in the ass
what is the overall deal with online
capabilities of the switch because when
they first explain it during the reveal
it was kind of cloudy they haven't
really explained anything and they say
it'll be a separate thing that will
launch like a month after something if
i'm not no remembering well i don't know
about the delayed launch but you will
get there will be a free trial period
for a certain time like six months or
something like that um and then people
have to start paying no idea about what
it's going to cost or what you get with
that yeah i think the subscriptions
start like paid subscription starts in
fall
i wrote that story i should remember
that yeah
you will be getting uh one free nintendo
or super nintendo game every month with
the service okay but i thought it
expires it expires
uh is it like a yearly thing what do you
mean by it expires after the month just
a month it's gone oh the game does
that's shitty it's not like a ps plus
you own in your library i mean it's
shitty only if you consider the fact
that playstation and microsoft have sort
of established these new norms yeah but
on the other hand if you think about it
just from a if you want to be positive
about it which is i think healthy in
some cases right like and
uncharacteristic
this is a thing that will bring people
together around a specific nintendo
franchise at the right time to make them
feel like there's a strong community
maybe before the launch of it sure use
all the game or whatever um so it does
suck they're taking it away but they are
actually introducing things for super
nintendo games uh like online
multiplayer
which has never been a thing for virtual
console before sure so that's pretty
exciting yes it sucks you'll lose these
games but virtual console games are
cheap right five to ten bucks
what kind of gamers would have
multiplayer for super nintendo like
zombies ain't my neighbors
star fox street fighter right that's
hopefully like the library the games
they release is good like month by month
well hopefully i mean i think the
biggest question right now is where
virtual console stuff from wii and 3ds
even transfer over
yeah that's the frustrating thing for me
because i've bought
many of these games multiple times in my
life and so
it's that's why it's frustrating you
don't get to keep it that expires but
obviously i'm i'm sure
we're more of a unique case than maybe
they're kind of thinking of people who
maybe you try you know
super metroid for the first time right
and then you kind of get into the series
that way and that's why it expires i
don't know i understand the thinking
there it's just i've paid ten dollars
multiple times for the same games when i
grew up there was a service called sega
channel through my cable provider where
i could literally subscribe to genesis
games on a monthly basis so i would get
like 12 games a month that i could just
play at the end of the month they'd
change to new games uh i didn't mind it
it was actually like a nice little
natural way of uh giving me some variety
you know uh yes it was there were
limitations involved but at the same
time it was
it forced me to try new things so
yeah because that was what i was worried
about i have a lot of uh like virtual
console games and then i know like
transferring between 3ds's when i got my
xl that was a pain getting like all
those like zelda games i had from my
regular 3ds to the xl i'm hoping they
can figure out how to streamline all of
that they have the my nintendo account
stuff like set in stone now and that
only came out about a year ago i want to
say
so it stands to reason that they've
figured this out they understand the
criticisms um so
uh
i would be shocked if your purchases
don't carry over let's say that yeah it
would be a really bad pr move for
nintendo absolutely
so um and i also wanted to just kind of
get your impressions with hands-on
because we saw a lot about the joy-con
and we saw that you can put ice cubes in
it and shake it around did you did you i
mean i'm assuming you watched the reveal
the night before you went to the hands
on what was the point of showing that
uh so the rumble feature in the
controllers um
which they call hd rumble
is different than what you you'd imagine
from a typical game controller um so the
game i was describing earlier and
similar to the ice cube scenario i had a
little one you know virtual wooden box
with balls inside of it and i had to
tilt it various ways and like
guess how many balls are in the box
so while tilting it i could feel the
balls like rolling down the controller
right and like hitting a certain spot so
you actually get a more tactile
sensation that that recreates some
virtual thing in the palm of your hand
uh so the reason for showing that on the
the stream was to really communicate
there's something different here but
it's really not until you get a hand on
it that you you actually understand like
oh yeah this this does feel different
so you see any like applications for
that in the future with games outside of
just this that proof of concept
i don't know sure they would i'm sure
like maybe it'll be in breath of the
wild somehow oh i mean we're going to
see it incorporate in a lot of stuff
yeah i mean it's one of their it's one
of the key differentiators of the switch
it's one of many but i think nintendo is
for better or worse focused on
highlighting the things that they're
doing differently right i mean for the
worse they made the gamepad a
requirement for every wii u game pretty
much this time it seems like it's softer
more smaller features they're going to
highlight so i think that they're going
to continue that trend but it just won't
be as obtrusive in general from your
hands on time can you tell us what you
thought about this just i don't know
general terms the switch how'd it feel
between the joy-con and actually like
playing it mobile and also when it's
docked and you playing on a tv sure so
playing breath of the wild um on a tv
using the pro controller pro controller
is incredibly comfortable i like it more
than any other controller out there
right now which is a shock to me um on
any platform yeah yeah
um
and you know the gameplay on the tv i
they put me really close to it so it's
not a fair comparison necessarily like
playing on a couch
the game had a lot of jaggies it didn't
look that better than that much better
than a wii u game that said i'm not
surprised right i mean this device is
pretty thin it's not purported to be
twice as powerful as wii u it's just
purported to be a portable game console
so in that sense it's like okay breath
of the wild is pretty much what we saw
back at e3 on switch
the difference being now that you can
take it and play it on the go with the
you know the joy cons and the tablet
playing with the joy cons attached
felt a little strange
more comfortable than the gamepad but
still not quite natural but if you use
the kickstand in the back of the tablet
and prop it on a table and disconnect
the joy cons and just hold one in each
hand
that felt surprisingly good
so if i'm in a scenario where i can put
the tablet down somewhere and actually
detach those i will do that before i
will hold it in my hand okay um but when
you go and you play a you know a
multiplayer game and you use the joy
cons as individual controllers they feel
a little strange
for one they are not the same setup the
joystick and the buttons are in
different locations to accommodate when
you do have it attached to the tablet so
in a two-player scenario it's a bit
unconventional in that sense like you
have to reach over to use the analog
stick kind of far right when they're
attached the analog on the right is
going to be
well it's oriented vertically rather
than horizontally so vertical is the
priority when it goes to a horizontal
fashion that's when it sort of shows
like yeah this is
this will work but it's not ideal um
[Music]
but that said you know pretty
pretty pretty happy with the hardware
overall it feels
unlike the wii u and even the wii it
doesn't feel like a toy necessarily it
feels like a really nice piece of
hardware
throughout the various products that are
involved okay
but in general was it
easy to figure out everything between
docking and going mobile it's all pretty
streamlined in terms of figuring out
completely intuitive okay yeah i mean
every game just reacted as i would hope
when i disconnected or connected
something what did you get to play aside
from like breath of the wild and the one
two switch stuff were those the only two
uh no i played um
uh street fighter which is not that
exciting
um
arms you talk about arms yeah yeah
because those ones we were talking about
yeah i'm really curious about that
actually yeah so this is a game that you
don't have to use motion controls with
but that was the only way i could play
it so that's the only way i can really
speak to it um and so you sort of if you
do you guys know virtual on virtual on
the old sega series no so it was a twin
stick game where you had like two like
flight sticks let's say and you had to
use them to like move robots kind of
like tanks in a way so this kind of
mimics those same controls so with you
know joycon in each hand you tilt both
hands in one direction to move your
character that way and then through
various button presses and motions you
direct them to jump punch parry or
unleash like a super attack um
it's
it doesn't seem like it's an intuitive
game but give it to 10 minutes and you
actually pick it up pretty easily
mastering it is not so simple but being
able to be an effective
boxer
that that comes pretty quick i do like
the idea of kind of delayed attacks
because of the length of the match so
you have to actually lead someone or you
know like actually think a step ahead
rather than just like a fighting game
which is very reactionary correct not
that you're all good fighting game
players will be thinking a step ahead
but armed especially because the
distance between the two fighters looks
kind of interesting yeah i mean there's
definitely like you get into that moment
where you're like
yeah where like time slows down and you
have to kind of think about like okay
what are my options what are they gonna
do when you screw up and you get
punished it feels bad but when you
succeed because you thought of a
strategy and enacted it effectively it
feels pretty great yeah and that it was
weird um arms will be releasing when
june i think we assumed it was a launch
title when they showed it to us right
now it's not i'm pretty sure it's june
yeah so
launch title in general once you switch
zelda
super bomberman
did you play that at all no didn't get a
chance to i'm a huge like bomberman 64
days yeah prepare to pay 60 for bomber
uh i probably won't i know i don't know
are you guys did you pre-order pre-order
a switch kelly are you planning on i
couldn't get it i was i was really busy
writing stories but you want during yeah
i want to i want to get it but i just i
couldn't get a pre-order and i really
want this zelda master edition i
couldn't get that either yeah that's the
one that actually comes with the master
sword fifth eye statue
so bad in general i think
uh the joke right now is that the switch
is like a zelda machine at launch it's
like you're paying 350 to play zelda
yeah but you know what like i said
before it looks exactly like the wii u
version so if you're on the fence and
you're like oh i've got to play zelda
don't worry if you've got a wii u just
honestly you could play it there and be
happy i think i was playing wind waker
hd on the wii u last night and i was
saying you know what game looks the same
as this like in terms of visuals like
breath of the wild kind of doesn't look
all that much better i mean it looks
gorgeous it's a gorgeous art style and
whatnot but yeah no it's a great
aesthetic it's vibrant it's clean you
know it's very cartoony and charming but
it's not like a technically demanding
no representation i mean you say i mean
you're a huge anime fan cali you said
the trailer that we saw for breath of
the wild the ex the longer one was very
animated it was super anime i was really
surprised it was like a ghibli i get i
yelled out a lot for ghibli or ghibli i
don't know i say ghibli i say but um
yeah it was a really good one
dvd
oh yeah you're right it's not ghibli
well as a kid i said ghibli but you're
right anyway that's not really what
we're talking about but yeah it was it
was super annoying
um especially like zelda crying was like
the most anime crying i've ever seen
from from just weeping but like sounding
like yeah yeah um
yeah so i don't know that made me more i
was already super excited i was gonna
say i i probably will play it on my wii
u just so my wii u gets some use and so
i can justify the
the money i put into it um but i i
really want the math tradition i might
be that person who buys the master
edition and then just plays it on wii u
but i want the magical sword um so like
that's to give you a picture of how in
deep i am with this game already um did
you get the chance to play it at e3 last
year
okay yeah cool um it was like our i
think i played it twice i went back it
was a lot of people at gamespot before
you got here like favorite game at e3
just like that was we came back to the
war room at e3 and it was pretty open
demo so we all came back and already
after just an hour each with the game or
40 minutes or something whatever it was
we were all talking about these crazy
things we did that we had no idea you
could do like these emergent situations
like everybody did a different thing so
i went back with uh miranda sanchez who
who's at ign um and she did a different
thing and we kind of she picked up where
i left off and she's like she went to a
mountain that i didn't even find and
like went sailing across a lake and it
was just really cool that everybody
found a different thing in that demo um
and so i was really excited like i can't
wait to explore that game on my own time
and really see everything there is to do
and try different recipes and like
there's just so many layers to it yeah
um and that's really exciting for me i
like the openness of it
um but i didn't really get to do it like
a mini there's like mini dungeons i like
started one and then my time was up
there's like 100 of them right yeah yeah
my main time was spent going at like
doing stealth around the enemy camps
bokoblin or moblin camps or whatever
they're called and then just like
stealing their weapons before they could
get them because they didn't have their
weapons in hand they're just sitting
around
yeah they're just hanging out that's
cool i like that a lot and then i didn't
i tried the cooking briefly didn't
really get it he humps figure it out he
comes during the cooking it's soaking
like a hobbit making potatoes what's
potatoes taters damn it boil them stick
him in a stew
just side note uh if you're gonna
download legend of zelda breath of the
wild digitally this also leads me to
another question that a lot of people
had in terms of memory and whatnot but
breath of the wild if you download
digitally will take up over 40 of the
console's base 32 gig internal storage
yeah and that's not even taking into
account like how much the os picks up so
it's like right i think it's 32 years
like half already yeah and so it's 13 on
wii u and 13.4 on switch and so that
doesn't even account for how much the os
will take up so you're you'll have
probably even less than 60 left yep that
makes sense so people a lot of people
asked actually so this is probably a
good time to get to the reader questions
and whatnot obviously i don't know if
you can answer all these but from your
experience and from your experience
covering it and whatnot um they did ask
so external hard drives will be
supported right at launch no dude
they're not no people no but micro uh
xdhc cards will okay uh and i
i might be wrong the limit is either
two terabytes or 256 gigabytes i don't
know if they i don't think they have two
terabyte sd cards but i could be way off
i think i saw that an article yesterday
and it made me scratch my head but 256
gigabytes is definitely available uh so
you can you can buy those and you can
you know quadruple your space okay yeah
people ask that was from bob jones 198
on uh twitter though he was asking yeah
he was asking if uh switch would dock
switch doc would support external hard
drives and he asked if pokemon stars
will be a switch game that's this game's
not confirmed
i think that was mainly a joke from him
but i figured i'd ask anyway um did you
hear whether there's like a trophy
system in place with a switch uh no
people suggested that i asked that but i
didn't have enough time i'm not talking
to you okay because i haven't heard any
news i don't know if you did callie i
haven't heard anything okay yeah because
i andrew jelly on twitter was asking um
and what you got really nintendo's style
so i i mean if i had to guess i would
say that that
probably wouldn't be i mean nintendo's
just not what are what are the things
that the wii u has like badges or
something what are the nintendo badges i
don't know the wii u but they're they're
changing stickers and games
but they're changing all that me versus
gone street pass is not a thing yeah um
but again these my nintendo accounts
exist and correct me if i'm wrong but
super mario run does have like a
like a small achievement like system
right it does yeah so if that's any
indication yeah maybe there will be i
don't know they don't i know nintendo
kind of likes to put that on the back
burner because like it's more about the
experience than showing off like how
much you completed which is just i mean
historically that's their style so if
they did i i imagine it would be
kind of more hidden or more minor sure
but i don't know and that was joshua
harman on twitter thank you for the
question about the trophies or
achievements or nintendo equivalent um
and then i wanted to ask someone i just
kind of wanted to touch on the price
itself which we brought it up obviously
but uh psych on gamespot was saying
prior to the latest switch event was the
first time i've been open to a new
nintendo console in a while i haven't
owned one since n64 i'm heavily a pc
console player and haven't owned a
mobile system since the game boy color
but the idea of a device that combines
the two sounded great to me with zelda
and mario to boot
but then that was until the latest
streaming event 300 sounds like too much
to me particularly with no packaged game
that's putting in competition with ps4
xbox one both of which have skews easily
acquired at around 250
with a bundle game and are much more
powerful
and it doesn't compete with the 3ds
which can be found cheaper ultimately
i'd be paying 360 for zelda which just
isn't a big enough driver so
uh sayak wanted to know what you guys
think of the price and lack of bundle
options i think we talked about the lack
of bundled stuff you know the switch one
two switch is a is a no-brainer so
that's done that's not included yeah um
i don't buy the comparison to ps4 and
xbox one because this is a totally
different product this is not a system
that's like hey we're a powerful gaming
system and we're gonna have all the
third-party games you love come play
them here and not those other places no
this is a look we're a nintendo machine
we've got some really weird interesting
stuff going on that you can't do
anywhere else
um so naturally you're paying more for
these
bits of hardware that aren't just the
tablet itself
um
so yeah i mean 300 does seem a little
bit high but if you consider the cost of
nvidia's shield tablet which i think is
200
basically it's the same tech the switch
is a little bit smaller in terms of
dimensions
but again nintendo's packaged in a lot
of extra stuff
i think 250 could have worked 300
doesn't seem too far out of left field
yeah i'd agree with i i was i put my
money on 250. we were kind of getting
our predictions together but i don't
think 300 is outrageous
what do you guys think this
in terms of the switch being kind of
also obviously like a living room
console but also a mobile device what
would this mean for like 3ds and whatnot
things like totally totally different
experience you don't think they compete
at all no i don't think they will
compete at all the 3ds is compact enough
depending on the model you can fit in
your pocket you will not do that with
switch unless you're stupid because
you'll probably drop that thing or sit
on it it's it's just too big to
to live inside of a pocket
even then the 3ds is super portable it's
got better battery life it's got a lot
of games built into it you don't want to
play console experiences the same way
you want to play a 3ds game which has
typically tailored experiences for
portable gaming right so maybe you only
have 15 minutes on the bus right you're
not going to want to jump into mario
odyssey for 15 minutes when you can play
something that's built to be fulfilling
within that limited amount of time so
you see the switch more as in terms of
being mobile you see that more as like a
road trip device or like playing in a
different room of the house it's a
matter of yeah it's a matter of
convenience rather than um it's it's
it's real identity i think it's a
convertible it's not a portable
yeah like for me the the main draw is
i'm super nearsighted and so my tv is
like slightly too far for certain games
and so having the option to bring it
closer is very different than bringing
my 3ds on bart and playing pokemon for
20 minutes on my commute and being done
with it and kind of
like being satisfied versus playing
skyrim and just having it closer to my
face yeah um yeah i can't when i'm using
a 3ds i can't i don't really play like
3ds on my commute or anything like a lot
of people do i can't really
get into a game the same way that i
might if i'm at home obviously but
i don't know the switch seemed like when
i heard about the switch i thought oh
that's awesome i can keep playing
something it sounds like what i thought
the wii u was originally supposed to be
something i could take on the go which
that's was my main concern with the
switch
it's really i'm i'm probably gonna
pre-order it and i love zelda and i
think i just want to be back on
nintendo's side or at least i'm always
rooting for nintendo but i want to get
back like i want to be involved again
and the switch is my chance to do that
especially considering zelda's launching
with it i try to play every zelda like
day one but
i was really hoping it would actually be
um actually like a mobile slash kind of
living room experience but of course
that doesn't make sense for them because
the 3ds does really well for nintendo so
why would they step on their other foot
by doing that right i mean look at the
battery life it's three hours tops
pretty much so i mean yes you can hook
up a battery if you want like a usb
battery and power this thing on the go
but
back to your point about the wii u
anyway about you know being portable
even just within a home a wii u gamepad
is not as portable as it should be no
like i can never get a good signal
whenever i try to do that remote play
so now there's just no questions like
there's no you're not jumping through
any sort of like weird technological
hoops to do it you just pick it up play
it put it down attach controllers that's
it there's no caveats yeah and i do want
to go back to what you said about this
is what the wii u what we all thought it
was supposed to be and i i sort of see
them kind of expanding on that idea and
improving upon it and i do think the
portability throughout the house is part
of that like if you're sharing a tv if
you are in the living room and like
somebody else wants to play a different
console or watch tv or whatever it is um
having the ability to move unlimited
versus the wii u i couldn't even go into
like when i was in an apartment i
couldn't go from the living room to my
bedroom like it just didn't work um and
so i think that's an another factor uh
versus taking it outside and going to an
a completely new location with it yeah
because
once i played i don't know like wind
waker hd i realized oh they're just this
tablet is just supplementing the
experience of tv i see my map and
everything and then if i want to be like
in my kitchen next to the living room i
can play it for like a few minutes while
i'm cooking something but yeah i'm not
gonna be able to take this on the bus or
anything but not that i would take a
game pad on the [ __ ] bus but it's
still um somebody would i guess they
would but i guess my oh speaking of uh
battery power josh shaw former gamespot
was asking can you charge the cable
while playing the tv or does it need to
be docked
for the three hour battery life that's
what i was saying earlier you can use uh
battery oh you didn't mention okay yeah
as long as the amperage is correct you
can charge it while playing okay cool um
and then i guess my last question before
you close out this segment kind of a
loaded question but the point of the
segment is
what do you think the switch are you
optimistic now the switch is announced
or do you think it's
i don't think it's too little too late
but i'm of the opinion like i said it
seems very much like what i thought they
were going for with the wii u and
it seems like they're going for the same
audience they were going for with the
wii u if i was to believe reggie during
his interview where he said that okay
our biggest failing with the wii u was
the lack of games so if i'm to believe
that he said we're taking this seriously
and that's something we're addressing
with the switch which you know we will
offer a steady cadence of of nintendo
games and third-party stuff
i think this thing will be okay
i don't think it's competing with the
other consoles it's competing for money
that might go towards other gaming
experiences but i think anyone who
invests in a switch and likes nintendo i
i have a hunch that this will work out
better than the wii u it doesn't even
it's felt like for a couple generations
now that nintendo hasn't even been
trying to compete with the other
consoles in the same way that they might
be just trying to corner their own
demographic and it seems like they're
not even attempting to you know compete
with the power of the other consoles or
the same audience right yeah that's not
their deal they do
totally different things and that's why
some i mean experiments sometimes fail
so
the wii u is like okay we're gonna try
this thing it didn't work and so if they
go back to switch and have the games
then i i'm also optimistic about maybe
getting a better install base than the
wii u had
i do i do think that the
not that it's a mobile system but the
option to play
sort of handheld esque is um
more palatable to the nintendo audience
i think nintendo's success has been on
handheld for some time now um and so
people who are already really into
nintendo games are accustomed to playing
them that way and so having that option
is really smart i think
yeah so in general i'm i'm optimistic
i'll be pre-ordering it when i get the
chance i did not yet but i don't know if
you still have the chance there they'll
have more in stock before they release
it that's intense speaking of things
nintendo always does don't they always
try to create the demand up front
they're only selling 2 million worldwide
at launch all right well i'll get it
i'll find someone who got a couple
maybe there's two people in the office
that got two each oh okay then you'll be
okay i don't know i want to buy one you
have to do just enough rain on your
parade brown over here just
all right anyway that is uh that was our
long discussion about the nintendo
switch pete thanks so much for your
hands-on insight on those joy-cons and
those cow udders uh anyway for those
people watching uh leave us your
thoughts in the chat if you haven't
already or leave your thoughts in the
comment below if you're watching this on
youtube or gamespot and let us know
whether you're going to pre-order a
switch what you think about the launch
lineup what you think about nintendo's
future
all right um
callie we're going to have you on for
this one more segment they're going to
kick you off for mary kish her last
lobby that's fair of her life
[Music]
uh because we just fired her earlier i'm
just kidding mary is in no way fired
she's leaving for uh you know greener
pastures
in her eyes
i'm just joking no i know i i had a joke
but it's probably not yeah cows greener
pastures was it called back to the
milking game no it was a switch
you have that on your mind get your mind
out of the gutter all right we're just
gonna do uh
more fun
get your mind out of the utter we're
doing a more uh a funner segment just
our what are our favorite nintendo
franchises because we were just talking
a good segue we're talking about we
would love to see nintendo focus on
games again which it doesn't seem like
they have been but
at least they're launching with zelda
it's one that we've played and it seems
really fun so far um obviously zelda is
an easy place to start i've been
replaying i just beat majora's mask 3d
again on the
um nintendo 3ds i beat ocarina over
break i play both of those once a year i
try to and now i'm playing through wind
waker hd just in between everything else
i kind of try to play zelda throughout
the year would you have played skyward
sword this year no not yet this year
it's january 19th 18th yeah dude clock's
ticking
all right i'll try to play one zelda a
week did you do you like skyward sword i
do i
hate the introduction to that game the
first two hours are the most boring two
hours of zelda i've ever we're talking
about skyward sword right yes okay
twilight princess doesn't have a fun
beginning either neither is wind waker
no but skyward sword is like have you
played a video game before let me tell
you what a sword is it's a thing that
can cut enemies you press the a button
to swing it with your arm fee your guide
fee phi i think it's fee if you're sure
whatever yeah she tells you how to solve
puzzles throughout the game yeah i don't
like her okay i actually like skyward
more than most people i'm not just
trying to dog you but i don't like fee
she tells you like oh maybe if you put
this electric ball in that socket it'll
power it it's like sweet fee thanks
game's got flaws if i wanted a built-in
strategy guide i would have
built in a strategy guide if i was
making that
game that was my first assignment at
gamespot was writing the the game guide
for
skyrim really really the dungeons in
that game are really good the one where
you have the tablet up in the first
section it's like a grid and you're
rearranging the rooms to fit them yeah
that was really fun dungeon
in general that game is actually really
well designed and i like the flying a
lot as opposed to the sailing wind waker
which i like but i didn't worry about it
and mine the motion controls i kind of
liked them no the wii motion plus it
felt good yeah i don't like the art
style whoa i really don't like the
watercolor distance background i feel i
think it's just zelda's face and like
link's face i don't like their faces and
that's so weird i'm like so totally like
toon link loyalist i love tune like more
than really my life
but
i just that's the that's the one thing i
couldn't couldn't get behind that's fair
for real i don't know why i think it's
totally not a popular opinion i just
don't like it
but zelda did look a little weird yeah
right yeah so is uh wind waker your
favorite zelda um no my favorite zelda's
majora's mask yeah
p what's yours
uh link to the past guess what mine is
i don't know mike majora's mask yeah
oh okay okay i always have to separate
it if you're doing 2d zelda versus 3d
zealot because i think they are a little
bit different so link to the past is
always my runner-up choice because i
love that one also i think link to the
past is as close to
perfect as a game i've played yeah
i'm not a critic or anything
not yours
uh okay i think the game like totally
nailed like immediately the presentation
and how you brought it into the story
right like your uncle goes out to like
solve some [ __ ] you find him and he's
dying he's like take this sword you need
to do some stuff and save the princess
like all right it's a dark and stormy
night you're like down in the dungeons
doing stuff like you rescue the princess
like it all just builds up so fast
and then you're left essentially in an
open world right and it has a typical
zelda metroid thing where you got to
find items to progress and look for new
things but you have a lot of opportunity
to scour the environment for interesting
stuff
so then you get to a certain point and
what do you know you can change the game
and flip it on its head and go to like a
dark dimension version of the world
awesome you know i love that when games
do that uh symphony of the night did it
really well but link to the past did it
best first
um and it's just a great progression of
skills and abilities and equipment
culminating to a final battle again and
that was pretty cool yeah um twitch user
gorman was saying link between worlds is
uh actually really quite good and i
agree speaking of link to the past i
think those games are sort of similar in
the way they're structured overall no
that's false
false objectively false yes i just said
similarly structured
mike you do you do a light you do know
and then you go to a mirror world wait
what structure are we talking about here
because the link between worlds you
literally buy the item or rent the items
okay okay i mean in terms of i
understand i've played both games a lot
okay link between real zones you buy the
items you get you rent the items from
whatever his name is and then after a
while you can buy them and when you die
you lose them if you have not bought
them i'm talking about just the whole
second half of the game is in a dark
world sure that's all i'm saying that's
all i'm saying that's all you're saying
please don't interrupt me you meant
thematically then no it's not
thematically link between worlds is more
about the existential dread of being a
character in a game whereas links to the
past is more about like are any of us
really
permanent beings no we're not
maybe there's a dark world in all of us
you want to talk about
you want to talk about visuals gets
angry sometimes when pete brown calls
him out
a link between worlds i could not stand
the i liked like the general art style
but whenever it did the like the 2d i'm
art moving along a wall wait we were
rolling b-roll when you just did that
you guys missed my dance do it again
when you were doing what
the thing where you're like shifting
around a wall yeah there we go okay
i can hear last night
um
but you're like the hype i no longer
like link between worlds after seeing
what you just said you're always going
to see my dumb ass just link between
worlds is one of the best zelda games
ravio that's the snake oh yeah it was
you really knew that
no it's a great game but it's
no link to the past that's not what i
had said i just said they were similar
in structure
um it was implied majora's mask uh is my
favorite by far it's my favorite game
i really love majora's mask
i uh when it came out on 3ds i went to
the midnight release and then i played
it like for a week straight so much that
my eyes hurt
and
i hadn't done that in years you're the
person that that warning is for at the
beginning
why are they saying how every nintendo
game is like like the newer ones are
like you should take a break like i'm
the person that's for like get out of my
way i want to keep playing and i was
like i'm 100 in this uh and i might die
doing it yeah leave me alone uh
you won't even have a trophy to show for
it i know i literally took a picture of
the you talk to the kid and he's like i
have nothing left to tell you or
whatever he says and i was like yes i've
done it this is my achievement
i'm seeing
just x kaz in the youtube chat has said
several times ocarina is better than
majora's mask uh about like a year ago i
would have agreed
and it probably is better but i like
majora's mask more
and i think majora's mask is super weird
and bold especially considering the fact
that they were riding on the coattails
of ocarina which is established like 3d
adventure
tropes now but at the time were really
novel majora's masks following up on it
like how super weird was you're looking
at the boss fights right now here's uh
uh
guy org
before that
here's a goat kelly you were saying is
one of your favorite boss i really i
just have a lot of fun with go i mean
like so when i say it's my favorite
zelda that's more of a like personal
thing than a objective critic i mean i
don't think there's total objectivity it
has serious flaws but um i just love it
thematically so much i love the dark
angle um i love how creepy and weird it
is
weird i love the like side quest
structure a whole lot um like the cafe
quest is
i love it cafe and anju yeah yeah the
the game in general i like its focus on
side quests like you were just saying it
there's only four main dungeons unless
you count like the end and whatnot but
unless you want to count like the uh
gerudo fortress the pirate fortress like
this but yeah everything looks way less
cool when he has the bunny hood on
he doesn't run faster i opt for the
bunny hood over the opponent
i have the the majora's mask nine droid
and i put the bunny ears on him on
purpose nice i like it yeah as much as i
would love to talk about zelda for like
another hour if not more uh anyone get
onto other nintendo franchises uh i
guess mario is an obvious one
what about uh odyssey what do you think
about odyssey being set on the switch in
like a
semi real
new york city new donk city new donk
city but don't get down i feel really
weird about this game i don't feel as
good as a lot of people seem to i mean i
don't want to say that i feel super
positive i'm not down on it i just i
have no idea what to expect from it like
how
how
we're over on bleecker uh there's a
short italian man running around
throwing the sentient hat at people i
don't just go back to the mushroom
kingdom
what is this what are you doing this is
yeah he actually there's a question mark
on the cross street crossing sign that
street was called expresso street and i
just noticed that for the first time oh
dang espresso or express it said
expresso i wasn't mispronouncing it it
just jumps off i do like the idea of
mario navigating an environment like
this yeah i'm just curious how the hell
it's going to make sense in context of
the world that he existed but it's not
like guacamelee now oh yeah what do you
uh what's your favorite mario game pete
do you have one
it's it's either
it's it's super mario world okay it has
to be i mean i think i really like three
like a lot of people uh two
the american version of two is certainly
different in quirky um and obviously 64.
you know i mean there's so many good
mario games
super mario world is just the one that i
can instantly put in and get into right
away and have a hard time stop playing
yeah do you have one i do not have a
favorite oh okay i would just say i like
the idea that yeah yeah
there's there's no favorites
yeah mario 64 is like the nostalgia one
for me because i'm very young
but yeah yeah i grew up in the n64 yeah
and mario 64 is one of my first games i
beat by myself do you like yoshi's
island i don't love yoshi's island
your sound's really good
i like yo
every time are you mocking me no i'm
mocking the baby baby mario clarify next
time please because i just got really
offended you sound very similar to him
yeah that's true she should do a cosplay
oh god all right what about star fox
it's last outing was not the best star
fox zero you reviewed it what'd you
think of it you loved it
i liked it better at the end than i did
at the beginning uh
but it missed the mark
um
star fox zero on sorry star fox 64 on
3ds is the best star fox game hands down
they ported that game and did put a lot
of love into like brushing it up um and
i'd love to see nintendo revisit that
series but
i also would be okay if they never
touched it again
okay because i don't i don't think
okay let me put it this way if miyamoto
is in control of the series i don't want
him to make another star fox game
because he is admittedly hell-bent on
you know introducing new ideas and
changing things he doesn't want to do
the same thing over and over which i
cannot blame him but that's what people
want from star fox they want an
experience that feels familiar that just
has different challenges and a new
setting and new events i think most star
fox fans will agree 1064 got it right
everything else is not quite there and
of course the peak was star fox
adventures
ben howard this morning was telling me
how much he loves that game i like that
game it's one of my i think it's uh
under-appreciated did you ever play star
fox assault yes the namco made that was
right that was the next one after
adventures yeah i did play it that was
more like a rogue squadronish game
wasn't it yeah uh i don't remember did
you like it i didn't play a whole lot of
it because you can go into third person
on foot yeah it was weird yeah um
do you are you a star fox man kelly no i
don't know a lot about star fox i played
a little bit of 64. 64 is great uh and
then a bunch of people are john smith
just goes metroid so i guess that's good
yeah john smith on youtube if that's his
real name just said metroid
uh
yeah that is the one that keeps getting
brought up for throughout the wii u life
cycle and now the switch is coming out
we were wondering when is metroid gonna
come back if
it is because federation force on the
3ds was not too promising this is kind
of falling into the same issue that i
described just a second ago right where
nintendo really wants to do new things
with the franchises they have
zelda is kind of an exception but also
it falls into line because breath of the
wild is this sort of new open world
experience but it's also a return to
form it's kind of similar to the first
game in some ways
uh for metroid people want
quote unquote uh metroidvania or as i
prefer castle roid
um
and sounds like a weird steroid i know
it's not good there
are so many games that make that style
now so could nintendo really make
another one could they justify investing
in another game it's just going to
follow in the footsteps of the games
that followed in the footsteps of its
game
you know what i mean like that might be
just too redundant for them it's going
to start using its like the people that
followed it as inspiration now is that
even like a viable thing to do
so i mean i would argue that yes it is i
think because the gameplay is one
portion of metroid or should i say the
structure of the game uh but the
gameplay itself is important and it's
tied to samus directly and samus is a
character that people really like she
was not handled appropriately in other m
yeah um so i think
the metroid prime series is great that
handled her really well but i think
people need a new metroid game to really
just like hone in on the fact that samus
is a [ __ ] badass and she isn't an
adventure that you all want so i
just play play to your your fans
requests nintendo that's the only thing
i can
that's the advice they need they just
need to like follow through on that i
might be in the minority here but i
would actually rather see a more metroid
primish metroid i would be happy with
another one as well yeah that's what i
was gonna say i think just super metroid
is like you mentioned like i don't think
you're gonna get better than super
metroid in that style of game no but i
mean metroid prime even kind of you know
it it peaked in the first game i thought
like i felt like it kind of was like
diminishing with every new release
i like corruption more than echoes i
think echo is this the one that people
didn't like as much because of the whole
like dark shadow light play it was
actually kind of a stressful game i like
corruption a lot though but yeah i agree
much reprimand i think it's the best one
it's kind of like a metal gear solid i
like the metal gear solids less as they
go on
except for i like five a lot
it has nothing to do with the nintendo
that's a tangent how dare you yeah but
anyway metroid prime would be fantastic
uh what are the franchises there's a lot
of nintendo franchises can i talk about
animal crossing now oh yeah you want to
talk about animal crossing i do oh yeah
sweet yes message on uh youtube
just gave you the perfect is that you do
you have your phone under the table oh
yeah tired
i'm also the person who asked about
undertale which it would totally not
come to the switch because it requires
pc hardware anyway um so sell me an
animal crossing so as if people haven't
tried to already animal crossing is
basically just a game full of chores
um but what i like about it is it's um
it's one of my like
de-escalating my anxiety games
um i'll you just check on it for 15
minutes a day and you're slowly building
up to something really nice like you can
build up a really beautiful town or
if you want to have as much money as as
humanly possible um and so it's it's
like a slow burn rewarding uh like
feedback system of a game it's really
it's it's unique in that way and i
really enjoy it for that um i didn't
like city folk on wii i think it's
pretty
good on handheld i loved wild world i
think i played wild world every day for
two years straight
like
a big problem and then when new leaf
came out i lost my mind
so um and then i lost my save and
and that no i haven't played it and i'm
really sad never played a minute of
any animal crossing game so great i
played the original on gamecube and i
couldn't get into it too much but what i
do love about the series is that these
it's like your town is persistent
so if you boot up your gamecube save
now your town is in shambles everyone is
depressed nothing is good because you
haven't played it in 10 years it's on
fire everyone hates you i think that's a
really cool idea yeah you come back in
the towns for pete brown that's a name i
haven't heard in a long time yeah i'm
just dead if i didn't have as many games
um to play as i do i my whole plan is to
get it on my japanese language 3ds um
because it has the furigana like the
readings written above all the kanji so
it's really good for learning kanji um
basically it'll take a word spelled out
in one alphabet but then give you this
succinct but harder to learn
representation from a different alphabet
above that word so it's like sounds
intuitive
for all ages
uh kids don't know like know all the
kanji i think you need to know 3 000 to
be fluent or something it's a lot um
but
yeah i think the main selling point for
me is um that it is slowly rewarding
like the the best part is i can come
back to my town there's an ordinance um
because you're the mayor in new leaf and
so you can be like oh yeah the flowers
will never die in my town
make it so and then you come back and
your town's still beautiful
and it just it fills me with so much joy
i just and then the animals are your
friends
don't talk to justin haywald you guys
will just lose the entire day talking
about animal crossing that's all he ever
talks about it's true that and p cross
yes
oh man don't even get me started geez
did you play pokemon
no
uh
oh man
what uh did we miss any i mean we missed
a bunch but yeah those ones we want to
talk about any others you want to touch
on
we didn't i do want to say how excited i
am for mario kart 8 deluxe yeah because
they're adding a bunch of stuff and
they're adding two items like in double
dash um
which every double dash is always
everyone's favorite yeah it is so um
yeah
the gamecube mario kart game if you are
not familiar but so they're adding a
bunch of new features and uh mario kart
is like the one game that i will
challenge anyone to i'll get very
aggressive
um so i'm excited for that i want to see
new pilot wings
yeah people in the chat were mentioning
that too i didn't love the 164 or the
weird one like pilotwings resort and 3ds
but the original super nintendo one was
pitch perfect i think yeah get it pitch
playing geez
but with the new controls i think you
could integrate like that weird rumble
feature pretty well to like mimic the
feeling of like rudders or engines
failing or like different stuff like
that i'm grasping at straws here but uh
there's a bunch of people yat sobu on
the youtube chat as one of a few people
saying advanced wars did you ever play
advancements oh yeah intelligent systems
the company the studio behind um fire
emblem games
they made advanced wars and those games
were really solid fire emblem like sort
of has supplanted it but i think there's
definitely room and people are making
homages to that series now which says
it's about time nintendo
funds another one of those that's a good
call i was gonna say i liked uh i did
not play fates yet still but i liked
awakening a lot i wasn't i'm not too
psyched for um
fire emblem warriors yeah i like man i
thought hyrule lawyers was fun for like
a day yeah i
i was really into warriors games when i
was in high school and so i felt like oh
i'm the i am the exact market for fire
emblem warriors i still have to play
fates though yeah me too both of them
yeah three there's three
all three of them that's what i meant
just play revelations
[Music]
uh okay cool so yeah um obviously
there's a lot of nintendo franchise we
did not touch on uh it's not just
nintendo anymore but the 20th
anniversary of symphony the knights
coming up uh i know there have been
castlevania games on nintendo platforms
before synthetics one of my favorite
games i would love to talk about
castlevania extensively maybe next month
for the 20th anniversary of cynthia
tonight uh but anyway uh if you guys
have any franchise you wanted to talk
about leaving the chat right now i'll
try to call it out but also in the
comments below if you're watching on
youtube or on gamespot and uh feel free
to tweet any one of us tell us
why we should have talked about
uh i don't know
p cross more
yeah yeah or balloon fight more or
balloon fight or nintendo land anyway
all right who are you aware that's
probably one we could've talked about
people were mentioning
basically
yeah that's true they should've just ran
with it but someone in the chat said uh
pete you don't know how to play donkey
kong
they said gamespot doesn't know how to
play they were specifically attacking
you i think oh mark walton gave tropical
freeze at bum review because he said it
was too hard or something he said it was
hard to keep a decent flow which is
necessary for a platformer mark walden
was wrong that game is great never
played it
oh my god wow horrifying all right
moving on kelly thank you so much for
coming on your first episode lobby i'm
sure we'll see you around a lot yeah
thank you for having me yeah absolutely
we're going to kick you off for mary
kish's
last it's fair time on the lobby tell
her i love her yes we will see you back
in the bullpen okay thanks so much for
coming on get back to work
mary ketch is coming in
uh in the meantime
people just people know people are
saying oh it's a mark walton throwback i
met him a couple times i met him at
gamescom he's a he's a british boy yeah
yeah he uh he's the one who reviewed
bayonetta
two yes right ten yeah
mary are you in the 10 out of ten club
no just have you given it 10 out of 10
before
i wanted to
yeah yes
mary if you guys haven't read it yet
mary wrote a review for star duvet you
should go read it i can write
it's uh it's good mary
what uh what's up this is your last time
in the lobby well i mean like as a
gamespot employee we'll probably have
you on as a guest at some point in the
future yeah
so uh
you're always behind the camera a lot
doing stuff
producing this show and uh obviously
you've become
pretty huge staple at the game spot
office and uh you've been here what
three years now yeah um going on three
and a half years i was a contractor for
a really long time and i
started the lobby's first iteration with
danny um
like about three years ago which is
crazy to think wow yeah and watched it
grow and watch it become what it is and
um
now i pretty much do it all behind the
scenes um
with uh jean-luc behind the tricaster
and tay kind of helping running the live
show so it's cool to see it from both
angles and um of all the iterations um
this one's probably one of my favorites
i like um talking to the audience more
so this is good it's gonna be good stuff
yeah they've been pretty involved today
we have a lot of people in the chats uh
i do want to bring you on we are talking
today about just nintendo in general but
i wanted to touch on
our favorite nintendo consoles figured
this would be a good one to bring you on
because you had a different take on it
you were going to talk about the
nintendo 3ds we can get into that
portable yeah so nintendo platform might
be the more accurate um
description for this segment uh we have
giveaways and stuff later to get back
into but
yeah i'll start with you mary because
like i said you're not always on camera
this is the last time so yeah hit me
with your favorite nintendo platform i
kind of just prefaced it right yeah it
would have to be
the 3ds which has just been
so monumental to my life these last few
years it's like my go-to i put it in a
bag and i take it with me um it's just
done
such a great job at having really
quality games and you guys already
talked about all the really good zeldas
which are on the 3ds right um but
including like a link between worlds
which was gamespot's game of the year
2013 so you're talking really
high quality games some in which you can
only get on the 3ds and then in addition
to that i would say it's the most social
portable uh handheld that you can find
right now um from games like
super smash bros to mario kart it lets
you play with a pool of friends even if
they don't own the game and i think
that's
really cool and
innovative and i think every every
console should follow that right i think
if your friend has it you should be able
to play with them and enjoy that game at
that time a better example in street
pass yeah holy [ __ ] that is that was
such a smart move by nintendo it's
really fun and um i don't know if we
utilize it as much as like japan does
like it is incredible if you go overseas
uh
and then you like check your 3ds and you
get check-ins from people all over the
world all over the world who love their
3ds and they give you a little message
and they have little hats and they live
in your 3ds and they literally open it
up and i've i've contained a lot of
humans in there these are people that i
was near at one point in my life i like
that this little this little reminder
that there are other people that like
the same thing that you do um and to the
point where you know with a lot of
pokemon games and other games now you
can like
fight with them on the street right you
can like challenge kids and stuff to
fist fights that's right
especially if you lose
um i remember like being at a a party
like a kinda like one of those like lame
parent parties right but one of them had
a kid a young kid who was like super shy
i wouldn't talk to anyone had a 3ds we
played 3ds games like it was a very
social interaction that i enjoyed it was
a way for me to connect with another
dude that i would never been able to
connect with and then on top of that
they did a really good connection with
the wii uh with the wii u i was able to
play monster hunter 3
and connect onto the wii u and play
online with another person
awesome so i'm playing monster hunter
three and then i maybe have to go
somewhere i hop on a bus and i can
continue leveling up my character
i'd never seen that before i know you
could do that and that's such a
precursor to what it's doing now right
which is play at home and then take it
with you and keep playing um so 3ds is
very near and dear to my heart
it's funny like somebody just asked me
the other day like what's the best
handhold in your opinion and um
you that 3ds like it's just the most
social
friendly handhold there is that lets you
play other games with other people and
talk about games with other people i
love the 3ds primarily for its library i
think it's about the amount of awesome
games on there that you can't play on
any other platform is unreal and you got
to include the ds library with that too
because yeah compatible and like not to
mention like you said all like older
zelda games other like metroid games
around there well in general it's i
don't know it's one of my favorite
handhelds too it is my favorite handheld
that i've ever had but i'm just playing
like majora's mask 3d ocarina time 3d
lately between the those re-releases
between the you know the digital library
it's pretty unreal yeah it's so broad
too like really hardcore games like uh
bravely default that take hours and
hours and hours to play or maybe you're
just like more into a platformer and
then you should play shovel knight which
is like such a rad indie game like
you're talking about a huge specter of
games for all sorts of different people
that's just comfortable as hell
especially the xl i mean the original
one like cut into your palms a little
bit but i i could play for
a long time on the three the xl now with
the rounded corners and everything it
just the size is perfect you can bring
it anywhere but it's also big enough to
not feel like you're squinting
3ds is great
what is your favorite console pete do
you really do you wanna know yeah i
wanna do i wanna know or do i do you
really wanna know i really wanna know
peter brown it's the stupid nintendo the
super nintendo
uh surprise surprise the yeah it's not
if it's not collecting dust on peter
brown i don't care actually it's a super
famicom to be specific uh
what is that this japanese one
no uh okay just talk about excellent
library games like super nintendo yeah
super nintendo's got it have you been to
japan
you can go to japan
yeah
wait it's not a company i thought it was
just like a thing people made up anyway
shut up um
excellent library right a lot of the
things people say about 3ds you people
you could also say about the super
nintendo but one of the things i really
loved just growing up as a kid was that
the super nintendo seemed to just
nail
like the logical conclusion of like 2d
pixelated games at the time everything
the nes wanted to be the super nintendo
was and then some
and and even branched out introduced 3d
gaming in certain ways as well like star
fox for example totally unprecedented
for a console game um
so there are a lot of reasons why that
system will always be near and dear to
my heart but you know the games that i
love about it the ones that i'd play on
virtual console like
those originated on super nintendo and
so its legacy is still felt today um so
i'll always remember it as my favorite
what's a game you still go back to
super metroid hands down easy yeah final
fantasy 6
great i've been playing that right three
in america
yeah
yeah um and chrono trigger are you fan
oh my god chrome triggers
that is that is one of them he's gonna
cry
oh
no it's that game uh it
it was just a perfect storm of creative
visions and people working on it like
if you guys played chrono trigger before
yeah yeah
i don't know like me did you find that
like once you start playing it it's just
really hard to stop playing like from
the beginning of the game not like a
random session but when i whenever i
start playing chrono trigger the
soundtrack the series of events like
i just it feels great all over again
every time yeah the storytelling in
general is unreal yeah the fact that you
can finish it how many different ways
music is insane i like to listen to
music on like road trips and stuff like
that's got a fantastic soundtrack i'm
listening to it right now the characters
in general sing it for me peter i like
the characters
characters are really good um
except that robot damn robot oh what's
his name chibi robo
robo
uh the frog
yeah i was gonna
we had kind of brought it up earlier but
mine's the n64 it's what i grew up on um
kind of came of age so to speak uh
ocarina i remember we got ocarina of
time like day one in 98 would it have
been 98 uh between that majora's mask
playing goldeneye playing perfect dark
the rare shooters uh
before they started working on like or
when they were working like
banjo-kazooie and tui after that but
yeah i don't know i still remember
playing ocarina i had like i have four
older siblings and they were always the
ones buying the games i would just play
whatever they got and ocarina was the
one that remember i would always get to
like the water temple my brother would
have to do it for me just because
i don't know i forget how old i was in
98 i would have been really young but
too stupid to do the water dylan too
stupid to do the water temple but i
remember that was like it was weird that
really was once i beat ocarina i felt
like i could beat anything but
yeah there's goob fact mike became a man
thanks the n64 i don't know what you
think i did to that console
but uh expansion port huh yeah
neojet angel
what
the n64 hard drive is pretty impr okay
um
[Music]
the perfect perfect dark is amazing
according to neojet angel i completely
agree uh
not perfect dark zero on the 360. that
game is [ __ ] um
perfect dark in general the n64 is
fantastic
um
i
the n64 i still play you ever play road
rash
yeah that's a game that oh yeah
back when it was cool ah dude it came
nice
it was the thing to play on n64 the
licensed soundtrack i believe on road
rash no it had its own thing rush at one
point in like the most modern version of
those games had a license soundtrack
yeah the xbox one version
there's no xbox version i know uh yeah
n64 is by far my favorite
might be my favorite console ever
and that's i mean i love the super
nintendo i didn't really grow up on the
super nintendo i we had one when i was
younger and uh even before that when i
was even younger we had an nes but i
never really played those as much
because i wasn't old enough to do those
things on my own
just a wee tot
tiny little just a sparkle in my
father's eye he was the same proportions
just this big yeah yeah
just people put me in their pockets i
had to like i had to jump from button to
button on the controller
i sucked at mario i never got past that
first jump
they're probably ones that people wish
that we had said that we didn't bring up
though yeah um so in terms of launch
lineups i think the gamecube was wasn't
it really good was it super mario
sunshine
is that it
it's a really good launch lineup luigi's
mansion i think mansion i forget man
it's
the first time i played a gamecube was
in a mcdonald's remember they had those
kiosks set up i do not know mcdonald's
people know what i'm talking about if
you're in the chat and you remember
playing gamecube at mcdonald's validate
mike yes please
prove to them i'm not crazy uh no i
played it i played luigi's mansion uh
super smash bros melee was unreal on
that wind waker residual four metro damn
gamecube had a really good library
gamecube to me was like
the place the cool friend had like
that's where you went and that he had a
gamecube and everyone went over to their
house like into the basement wait they
didn't carry it using the handle on the
back of the system over your house i
don't remember the handle you guys just
run down the street like i remember
having a handle it was just a cube no it
wasn't it was a cute you're insane
it was like one big plastic breast
knuckle yeah
eat it eat it
get some chicky nibblers and then go
play some luigi's mansion oh man
there's the safe right infringement yeah
i can't say
what do they really are i don't think i
used to have uh i used to get a big mac
and then
just [ __ ] slay and super smash bros
melee
i used to like people used to come up
and put instead of putting quarters on
the the console you just put a little
chicken nugget and then i'd have to eat
it and then we'd play and i'd win every
time i'd never had to pay for chicken
nugget my whole life because i was
really good with marth and super smash
bros melee
and they say and they say games can't
pay the bills he was like the bully of
mcdonald's that ruled the kiosk mikey
mcdonald thank you mcdonald's they
called him i push open the door and uh
like a
buzz weed floats by is it buzzweed
you guys know what i'm talking about
when there's drugs i never know what
you're talking about anymore
i never do either um so that's the
gamecube what about game boy gameboy
color not that they're the same thing
but gameboy color link's awakening uh
gameboy advanced do you also forget
about oracle of seasons oracle vegas
oracle seasons oracle of ages those
categories all the games yeah and they
were good links awakening was
game boy originally link's awakening dx
and they added the color dungeon on
gameboy color that's a really weird
zelda but it's really good tumbleweed
thank you
what did you call them buzz buzzweeds
i'm thinking buzzfeed
420 buzzfeed there's some more all right
what is that uh anyway
uh
you kids want some buzzweed such a
fitting
dude buzzweed's legal here now
in like a year
tell me about it
getting arrested for carrying out all
that buzzfeed
i'm just trying to play some gamecube
games jesus uh
what other consoles are we missing i
don't know the wii
the wii u
people you guys the nintendo revolution
their favorite but the wii is
acknowledged as one of the greatest you
know revolutions i mean it just
completely took the world by storm and
everybody's
mom had a wee and they all did all their
exercising on it it was huge it was a
phenomenon and i remember
um my parents who hadn't played a game
in years were playing wii bowling and
thought it was the best and to me that
was worth it like that was cool because
your dad like [ __ ] that was a strike
and you know it
he wasn't even he wasn't even standing
either you know you played with you and
you were like this and you'd be like oh
that's
[ __ ]
it's like this shitty person but it was
a fun family game and people liked
playing it together and it did that
really well and you have to acknowledge
that it was i was really cool
peter duke of wee bowling do you guys
know who norm duke is he's that famous
bowler who could do the things through
the chairs and with the towel and then
off people's heads we don't know what
norm duke is to tell
would you look at the time that's like
saying you're a football fan don't know
who like jerry rice is norm duke dude
the duke no one said we were bowling
fans so we just talked about bullying i
didn't bring it up you did all right
anyway i don't think virtual boy what
about that brags about bowling virtual
boy looks like an imperial probe droid
that had a great
you want to talk about virtual boys i
played or playing games in weird
environments i saw the virtual boy first
at a blockbuster they had kiosks there
like a month later they were selling
them because no one wanted it burger
king 30 bucks that's a lie
uh a great shooter from hudson soft i
know you guys all love hudson soft
properties that was name one bomberman
oh
he was ready get out here making stuff
up now um mario clash was an interesting
game um there was a like that wario had
a platformer oh they're oh
they had a boxing game on there that was
basically punch out in 3d it was great
tell a row boxer yeah oh man you guys
don't even know no speaking of boxing
games come to my house i have one you
can play it
speaking of boxing mcdonald's
there's a there's a bar in san francisco
called sodapopinskis and if you beat
mike tyson and to punch out you get a
bottle of champagne they discontinued
that i thought oh they're still doing it
probably because of dan riker did he do
like 12 times
yeah yeah uh
anything else you want to touch on
favorite consoles
nothing
did you uh
yeah we talked about them all i think
about the switch what do you think of
the switch no
no
i think that was their problem yeah all
right what about the nes the original
one go back to it what about it tell me
about it
you have like you have like six
collectors editions on on open oh god
would you shut up
uh i was born the same year as the nes
and i had an older brother and he bought
all the games and i loved it and uh it
was my introduction into uh video games
a lot of our introduction to video games
was probably nes right like that was the
one where you saw somebody else play
something
well at least most people at this table
i was too young but that was like where
you saw people play cool things and said
i want to play cool things too
i am known for loving metal gear and i
the first one in nes was like my first
experience with the series i could never
get past the second screen in that
freaking game but i played it all the
time to bomb random wall seems so cool
trial and error for me it was getting
around the dogs
oh
i played for like two minutes and then
realized it was a bad idea
not that a bad idea yeah what about the
new mini too the little guy classic um
it's cool the controller cables are too
short i saw that people around the world
have mentioned such short cables yeah uh
everyone is selling extension cables for
cables it's like but nintendo's not
having a problem selling this thing so
that doesn't really matter
um the game selection could be better
but that's splitting hairs you said
there was like uh trademarks or uh
copyright patents filed for nintendo
classic nintendo did something to
recertify its design of the super
nintendo controller so understand a
reason that we'll see them make
something with that controller be it
something for switch for virtual console
or a super nintendo classic
which i think would be in their best
interest cool
all right well that was our discussion
about not just our favorite nintendo
console but every nintendo console uh if
you're watching in the twitch youtube or
gamespot chats let us know you have been
it's been great and uh if you're
watching this on youtube or gamespot
afterwards let us know in the comments
below thanks so much
mary that was
your last lobby segment yeah
i've had i'd have a lot so this was a
good one yeah thanks for having me on
well
uh
so you've been here three years yes uh
our friend rob handler just walked in
the studio rob came in early yesterday
and was working tirelessly and
secretly he was working on a robot that
now that i think about it that doesn't
make much sense he has been uh chatting
us all secretly and getting clips
together and working on a fitting
send-off at least for our for your
presence on our live show so we have
something that rob has been working to
put together
and uh fiddling with audio currently
holding one second audio but jean lucas
there we go
all right all right i think we're good
john luke roll it
really
i can't believe i'm gonna do this
sauzbuck i choose you
you're probably asking yourself mary
what kind of video is this here's a list
of things gta does really well
thanks for sharing that strippers
decent hip-hop submarines strippers
rednecks gas cans sharks bicycles
redneck strippers this week on new
releases a little something for everyone
remember there's no wrong way to twerk
it's so darn cute
i just might die
electric stars to make your shoes fly
xbox one versus playstation 4 showdown
we've got four consoles set up here it's
gonna say if i pass the baton you guys
could see a squeaky bear that mary has
cutscene
i'm a plan dead rising 3.
eat my teddy
uh and i got a lot of people joined with
me i have a mary kish and eddie makuu
[Music]
we live we doing this thing
uh welcome to megabit everyone it's me
pete with mary back
[Music]
peter you have to join me
i can't do it no it's all
i'm mary and welcome to another game
spot plays i'm here with the lovely
kevin van orden oh how often do you say
wee
when you play a game i don't really say
it i think it in a way
we are going to be playing trying three
no where is the camera
danny dwight here with mary kish
yeah tag that jerk
gta on pc hasn't been out for too long
but the mods are already starting to
come out rob
he's not allowed to do it when he's
watching i'm trying not to put your
hands down
not the car
not the god damn it you think i don't
know about cindy happy fourth day happy
fourth to you as well what a fantastic
time we live in
july as well
it's my first tgs but it's my first time
in japan so i have like zero ideas
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's wednesday october 28th i'm
mary kish and you're watching gamespot
news batman arkham knight is gonna be
the first in the rocksteady studios
trilogy to get an m for mature rating
because they're gonna say [ __ ] in it
hey mary here with the gamespot news
update
today it was announced that sean is a
huge [ __ ] our second contestant
is zero suit mary kish yeah i'm ready
what was that
guys we got some construction downstairs
we hit a load-bearing wall we need to
get out of here right now all right all
right um when you have uh xbox gold or
playstation plus
oh my god josh what do i do
[Music]
let's be clear you're no way of sound
mind and body
eat it josh you're dead
what's up guys we are so excited to
start this new series with you this is
resident knievel
[Music]
all right guys here it is
e3 2014. right now there's some creative
genius going on it speaks for itself
yeah there's a definitely a lot of magic
behind the scenes i think it's probably
the second game in the history of
gamespot that have made our managers uh
have required specified times that we're
allowed to play it the new plan
is lock lag and [ __ ]
lag [ __ ] it's become the
quintessential game that we cannot put
down in fact there's been rules in place
because we play it so much that we're
starting to get in trouble
gaming is just the best
i mean where else can you put on a
headset and call someone a
newbie
needs to your
and feel really superior about it it's
awesome it's such a good game play it
right now go
spend it the way you want to do it as
joe dirt would say life's a garden
dig
[Music]
i'ma get out of here
i am so sweaty
[Music]
that was really sad thank you
yeah so that's rob hanlery uh
the least you know he could do what
anyone else could do send you off you've
become come here yeah yeah rob come over
on set it's your mug grab a mic quick
that video sucked to make
they're really hard to make really hard
to make mary has done them all and
obviously uh someone had to do it so
thank you rob you bet i thought you were
making a robot come here
uh yeah obviously you know mary is going
on to do some new stuff she will have
more news in the coming weeks or months
or whenever she
announces her next adventure but we're
all really sad to see you go i know like
pete you've been at gamespot for a while
uh i haven't been here long but she's
become a met you've become a mentor to
me coming over video team and everything
and i'm sad to see you going the office
is not gonna be nearly as fun or
uh we're gonna have to work really hard
to try to
keep the energy up with you gone
i
love this place
and i'm gonna miss every one of you guys
it's gonna be the hardest
it's hardest thing i've ever done
in my life
and um
i love you guys
we love you too mary
you've
you've been the highlight of
working again this is really hard
working with you has just been
incredible and i'm so happy to call your
friend so and i've you've grown in like
in measurable ways over the years which
is
more than i can say for you know some
people and uh you just consistently
impressed me so
geez
i was a scrappy little nobody um
i fought my way in here
and uh
i'm just so glad i was able to work with
you guys
i'm so excited i just love game spot so
much and i think 2017 is going to be a
really good year and i'm bummed i'm not
going to be there with you guys but i'll
be with you in spirit
i'll thank you guys every step of the
way
i am so glad i got the time i did with
you
sam
oh that video
i said that's my favorite part like
eight times
got all the good ones
yeah it's uh it's gonna suck to see you
go um we'll have you back as often as
possible obviously yeah i always want to
come back i wanna see what you guys are
doing i'm gonna watch you i'll watch
everything you do
yeah well uh it's been fun to start new
projects with you between dead air the
podcast we did for a while
starting work on the lobby producing it
with you and obviously resident knievel
is always a highlight of our week we
will be continuing that that's right
i had a lot of people ask me what will
happen with knievel and we made a
promise
and we're gonna keep it and i will come
back uh and finish knievel so i'm going
to just
come back once a week and we're just
going to keep making it so you can
expect
episodes of knievel every week until we
finish
all of them that's the plan i'll be i'll
be sneaking into the office somehow
we'll break you in through the air
events security can't stop me
now they can
alright well as always mary thank you so
much for helping produce this episode as
well as pretty much every lobby episode
ever thank you guys for being behind the
scenes as well as on camera for doing
all you do i can't
really sum it up in 10 seconds at the
end of an episode but obviously we'll
see you here the rest of the week we'll
have you back as often as possible
if the chat is any indication the
audience is going to miss you a ton as
well
i'm sure you've gotten a lot of
best wishes over twitter and whatnot and
we're really excited to see you announce
what you're doing next and everything so
we know you'll kick ass like rob said in
the video and we're looking forward to
seeing what you do
thank you guys and thank you guys for
watching and thank you guys for
supporting the lobby
and all the shows that we produce we put
our blood sweat and tears into them and
there's a lot of people that you don't
see
working back there to do things like
jean-luc and eric tay
and a lot of other people so
a lot of people work really hard here to
make things that you guys like so it's
good to acknowledge them
richard lee
richard lee the behind the camera
extraordinaire who's always
who's been running the camera for the
lobby for like ever so
there's like no lighting that's done
that he hasn't touched um jake decker
does a lot of behind the scenes as well
yeah and uh like i said your shoes can
never be filled but we'll do our best to
uh
keep his sight energetic and you know
doing creative stuff in the meantime
when you're gone keep that energy up
mike just try calisthenics like every
every before every show
do my hourly push-up
that'd be great we're going to weekend
at bernie
we're not going to kill you but
we'll carry around like a dummy with
your boy gun we have a dummy in the
office it's on the highlights which you
which was not in the highlight reel that
was actually you doing all those stunts
yeah i did every stunt here since i was
here so
[Music]
all right well mary do you want to do
the honor of closing the episode out
then
sure all right
i'll let you do it geez i've never done
this before i'll probably mess it up um
thank you guys for watching the lobby
this is our weekly
show about video games every wednesday
at 11 a.m now and we're so glad you guys
could join us and you guys make this
show possible and we want your opinion
and we want to know what you think so
message us message mike hardy on twitter
or you guys can um leave a note in the
comments so that we know what you guys
want to see more of because we do it for
you and um i'm gonna miss you guys
have a great day
[Music]
bye
you